today we're kicking it off um with a
miracle
ross it really is the story you're
not gonna believe it it starts back in
2013.
two women named julia and cassandra
met while working at a bar julia told
cassandra that she loved her dominican
flag tattoo and that she was dominican
too
born there and adopted there and then
cassandra said whoa
me too and they became best friends they
wore matching outfits
they told people they were sisters just
for fun and then they even compared
their adoption papers to see if by some
bizarre chance they actually were
sisters but the documents didn't match
up
oh well they stayed besties for years
well then people reports that julia
eventually took a dna test
and found her biological dad and he
revealed that he did
have another daughter in the united
states wow and they just ran the dna
test on cassandra
and yep all biologicals wow
that somehow found each other at a bar
in new haven connecticut
and it turned out there were just errors
in julia's adoption papers to begin with
i mean if this is an unbelievable story
it's like what you dream about you know
finding out
that there's some connection i always
wanted to find out that i was like you
know princess diaries i'm princess of
genovia somehow
you know but uh when i was reading this
i i mean i've never talked about this
um ever a lot of my friends don't even
know but
i was so envious that they found each
other because you know i've lost both my
parents
and my connection with my brother who i
have is uh
i i have learned that uh family is the
most important thing in the entire world
and um i have a relative
who um is out there who was given up
for adoption um and it's somebody who
my parents never got a chance to track
down and i
i read this and i thought to myself how
lucky
are these two women that they found each
other you know
when you when you don't know where your
family is it haunts you i think about it
every day
and i'm so envious of them and it it
really ignited something in me i i'm
really gonna
try to do what my parents never finished
i really want to find this person
ross is there anything that i can do or
you know if you'd like to start this
journey privately or
as your friend or if there's you know
anything
that i can do yeah i don't know i didn't
put that much thought into it i just
said it right now
i don't know so yeah i mean i i want to
i
the thing is is that it's clearly like
if you want to start this kind of search
how do you do it right
i don't know so i'm maybe i'll spend a
little time with google and
we can throw some ideas around but yeah
i have no idea how to do it
well sometimes the beginning of a
journey is just
realizing that the timing is now and
if it is and it's okay if it's not but
if it is
then you just we just start okay i think
i think it is okay yeah all right all
right
let's let's begin this journey okay
we'll see what happens right well
congrats to them you know sorry i didn't
mean to steal your thunder ladies but
congratulations
it's not about me it's about you but uh
thank you for that gift i think that's
an incredible story
i think it might be about you the fact
that their story which is
so extraordinary has sparked and
inspired maybe
a clock for you because timing is
everything
it is things happen for a reason just
like they were put in that bar for a
reason maybe i read their story
you read it here for a reason as well
that's exactly right right yeah
and we have lots more news i know you're
going to love this story drew because uh
you know we're obsessed with bridgerton
well it's the gift that keeps on giving
cnn reports that one small business
owner credits bridgeton with the runaway
success of her new venture
stephanie sinclair started her tea
company larue 1680
smack in the middle of the pandemic and
just hope for the best and then
bridgerton happened and stephanie got
inspired
she created a tea collection based on
what a duke and duchess might drink and
her business
took off like 500
increase in revenue and uh you know we
love this story we love bridgeton
and growing up like i didn't drink tea
like maybe i had a snapple on occasion
that was like yeah
which i'm not mad at but in adulthood
drinking tea has become such like a
little like
luxury for me it's very ritualistic
right
you totally feel fancy but it's like a
scent a bag
and her tea right here look how
beautiful this package anyway look at
this
yeah so it's loose leaf which scares me
god i know that really is adult
i totally adore i don't even have one of
these things i'm rocking the casablanca
what are you rocking
yeah i'm having a costa blanca as well
and it's so delish and robust
right i want to describe what is
happening i feel like i'm drinking a
rose garden
yes oh so floral i don't even understand
what it is but also
acidic and beautiful the way you'd want
like a hibiscus tea
mine's like empty i'm already downed it
oh my gosh this is going in the little
yellow book this is the best tea
ever stephanie congratulations oh
stephanie sinclair good for you
wow okay i'm not kidding wait until you
try this it's like
it it's a whole experience it's not just
a tea
it's not just for tea um okay and now
it is time to taste the good news in
food news okay
delish reports that reese's is taking
their famous peanut butter cups and
turning them monochromatic
with the ultimate peanut butter lovers
cup
oh my god bye-bye chocolate this is a
full
peanut butter party pb on the outside
baby on the inside
what are you doing to me these reese's
cups are a gateway candy for ross
matthews i don't
can't believe you're bringing this out
for me rossi i can do it if you if
you're
worried because you really are like
you're
committed and i'm like all over the
place i'm so grateful that you do that
for me as a friend but if you reach over
here i will smack your
hand okay you know we love peanut butter
so let's go
i'll remember oh my god what's it you'll
never you're never gonna want
the old one again this is leaps and
bounds
stephanie reeses thank you